[Music]
only three weeks left a summer I can't
believe that oh yeah summer
what are you cheering the end of summer
you want to get back at it that's an
unusual response yay all this relaxing
there been a lot of reports out there
that people have cut back on vacations
this summer and they've cut back on
summer fun because budgets are tight
because the economy budgets are tight
and people aren't spending as much on
their summer fun well we heard about
this don't worry we got you covered
here was some money-saving ways to enjoy
the rest the summer is our prop master
bill tall bill
[Applause]
take a squeeze bottle of mayonnaise
right spf50 on it boom sunblock parents
bill with another tip take some Windex
stick an umbrella in it boom tropical
drink here's another one take a pair of
glasses dipped in black paint boom
sunglasses
[Applause]
here's another one
take a pancake wait a month boom
frisbee
[Applause]
niku that beer in a mug he has to shave
six times a day that's my favorite still
that's my Christmas card by the way
[Laughter]
here's Bill with another one form a line
of people stand behind them for four
hours boom Disneyland here's another one
put on a white shirt take a head acid
boom Hawaiian shirt
[Applause]
take your maid sticker in a meat locker
[Music]
boom frozen margarita
[Applause]
find a kid with the kite take the kite
boom kite
[Applause]
you